when did it start for you when did you
start doing comedy or going to open mics
or when it actually occur to you that
hey I want to do this been a fan of it
for a long time
you know but I think after high school
is like like end of high school and like
beginning colleges were like I'm gonna
go for it and I went to an open mic and
I we're in Long Beach off of Anaheim
Street it was a bar one
Alexes bar no it was uh I think at the
time was called liquid lounge
oh I think it's still there is this
Dylan no I don't think so yeah Anaheim
street like it was right by my high
school and it was just the worst bar and
and I stuck in I was 20 mm-hm and I
asked the comic who was running it his
name's a Cochino you know yeah and I
asked him I said hey can I go he's like
dude you're 20 get out of here they're
gonna shut the place down I'm like well
if I come back next week and I get on
he's like yeah yeah whatever
yeah so I got past the bouncer yeah I
mean I've waited in the car and soon as
he like stepped out I was in there and I
hung out in the back that a little
ping-pong table so I just kind of like
sat there people were drinking I just
pretend to be friends you know laughing
at their jokes yeah and then finally I'm
like hey you said I could go up he's
like dude just go up so I go up and do
three minutes I bomb my ass off I
dropped the mic I tipped over the mic
stand it was so bad it was bad so I
didn't do comedy for a full year I'm
like this is not for me
so I go back at 21 do it again I bomb
harder than the first time Wow
harder yeah I'm like this is definitely
not a size thing but it'll you but
doesn't it feel good to bomb I mean how
it does on the back then if you in
retrospect even when I bombed right yeah
I was still impressed in the fact that I
did when I went up there yeah but that
was terrible but the one thing that I
wasn't proud because I never thought I
could do it I could is that you did that
yeah and then you're choosing to do it
again that's [ __ ] crazy yeah so you
should give me that wasn't that a
feeling like that
or no no I mean I had some weird ass
jokes I remember the first joke I wrote
as I because I read the newspaper and
there was
something with the death penalty and
there were somethings like saying how
tax dollars are not gonna pay for the
last meal so I said oh if I'm ever about
to get killed or whatever get the death
penalty for the last meal I'll ask for a
Red Bull because I heard it gives you
wings and I just looked around the room
that was a joke that was a joke I'm
gonna weigh it down I love that you
should have been there the old rocker I
open and close with that I said it twice
and it didn't work I got that fire man I
had one of my first jokes was I don't
know why but I said Vietnamese is such
an unromantic language you got a
beautiful girl in your arm right looking
right under our eyes you're right you're
open your mouth and you go you know I
just do yeah man and it was so happy but
I think I got a laugh because of the
just doing the Asian accent thing right
but like in the beginning that's what
you write because you don't know right
especially you know that what I mean I'm
sure you had who do you look up to Paul
Rodriguez maybe or no Lopez early on yes
George Lopez Paul Rodriguez because they
were like as a comic you're like who do
I resemble her who like what path do I
take so it's like these guys and then
the more I got into it the cartoons on
Saturday was life with Louie Louie
Anderson yeah a Bobby's world which was
Polly Mandela Howie Mandel yeah so I'm
like oh man so you just started an
expose down the line Don Rickles I
remember was like Don Rickles stood out
because he roasted and I loved that so
much and it was very much like immigrant
culture you know barbecues man grandma
star you know making fun of you your
uncle's your cousins and you just have
to hold your own defending yourself or
making fun of them so that's what stuck
out about Don Rickles and I just started
getting more and more enamored and now I
mean my two top favorite comics are JB
Smoove and Brian Regan Wow one
eighteenth of what Brian Regan or JB
Smoove has yeah like I've made it
haven't met Regan no he would love your
thing no I'm gonna go watch him
in November he's playing in Long Beach
at the theater like I can't wait
you gonna go yeah I'm going I'll go with
you yeah really
what's all of it I know I want me to get
it out that's it right now
what what you know him yeah he's the
best he's so nice
he's one of my favorites too
[Music]